بين التلال المذهلة في وسط
جورجيا ، يوجد دير صغير متواضع
وهو على ارتفاع مائة وثلاثين قدمًا
فوق سطح الأرض
[موسيقى]
catskil pilla عبارة عن صخرة طبيعية من الحجر الجيري
تمتد من المناظر الطبيعية
أدناه بينما يحظى الموقع بأهمية دينية
عبر التاريخ.
جلس فوق هذا العمود تغير على
مر القرون في الأزمنة الوثنية ، حيث
يرمز العمود إلى إله الخصوبة ثم
تحولت جورجيا إلى المسيحية خلال
القرن الرابع وأصبحت طبقة بيللا
موطنًا للأشخاص الذين يختارون العيش
في صلاة منعزلة ، ثم تم التخلي عنها
من جميع أنحاء  من القرن الرابع عشر حتى عام 1944 عندما
اكتشف المتسلقون أنقاض
كنيسة في عام 1997 ، وصل الأب مكسيموس
من الكنيسة الأرثوذكسية برؤية
لإعادة البناء أقام في قاعدة الأعمدة
بينما كان يعمل على
البناء الفردي للدير في الجزء العلوي منذ عام 2014
ولم يعيش فيه أحد بشكل دائم  الذروة
ومع ذلك يتم الحفاظ على الموقع باستمرار من
أجل طول العمر وعمل مهمة
الراهب كاتز كابيلا
يقع على ارتفاع منخفض
[موسيقى]